[Music]
hello my name is map and garcía I'm a
technical account manager at google
cloud today I'm going to tell you how to
manage identity and access to resources
on google cloud platform when
we work with the google
cloud platform we have to take into account who
has access to the resources and what
activities it can perform on each
resource, that is, we have to assign
iam policies, the acronym for
identity access management, the
iam policies are made up of three parts: a who,
what can do, and a resource, the part
of  who names the user to whom
the permissions are granted, that is, an
identity, the part can do that is
defined by a role, a role
is actually a collection of permissions
to grant a user the
desired permissions, a role is granted, that is, the
collection of permissions on a
resource whose party is say the identity
can be a google user account
a google group a
service account or  a full domain of ui
suite or claudia identity later
we will see what a service account is
most of the time to perform
any significant operation you
need more than one permission for example
to manage instances of
virtual machines in a project you need to create
delete start stop  or change an
instance so permissions are
grouped into a role to make it easier
to manage there are three types
of cloud roles and primitive roles
predefined roles and
custom roles primitive roles are the ones that
historically exist in
google cloud projects  platform apply to a
gcp project and affect all
resources in this project are the
owner roles editor and reader if you are
a reader on a given resource you can
browse it but not change its state if
you are an editor you can do anything
a  reader can do and also change
its status and if you are an owner
you can do everything that an e  ditor can
do in addition to managing roles and
permissions the owner role is on a
project it also allows you to do one
more thing set up billing
often companies want
someone to be able to control billing
for a project without the ability to
change the resources in  the project and that is
why someone can be granted
the role of billing administration
also a good practice is to grant the
owner permission to several members
of the team to provide continuity in
case the sole owner leaves
the organization or is eliminated  their
account for any other reason
another recommendation is to use
google accounts
for your project team members when someone
leaves the company
the domain admin should mark
the account as suspended instead of
deleting the account these roles can
be too generic in  projects
where several people work and you want to
control access  to the information
fortunately ian provides other
types of more granular roles
predefined roles fp services offer their own
sets of predefined roles and
define where those roles can be applied
for example computen gym is a
service within the
google cloud platform that it offers
virtual machines with foot also has a
set of predefined roles and you can
apply them to computen
gym resources in a given project in a
given folder or in an
entire organization for example a
managed database
service called big wall big table offers  roles
that can be applied across the
organization to a particular project
or even to stand-alone database instances
in this example we grant a group of
users the instance admin role on the
project and the instance admin role
includes a list of
predefined permissions  to manage
computing instances in a good
p  The practice is to define the permissions
using groups, thus facilitating the
management of personnel changes,
however for this reason
the ability to change the
policies and members of the group must also be controlled,
there is also the possibility of offering
a set of specific permissions, for
example such  Maybe we want to define the
instance admin role to allow
some users to start and stop the
computer gym virtual machines but
not to reconfigure them
custom roles are precisely
what allow us to do this however a
couple of caveats about custom roles
oblige  that you
manage those permissions and they can only be
used at the project and organization levels,
not at the folder level. We have
commented before that the identity can
be a user, a group of users or
a service account, a service account
is actually an identity
that your programs can use to
authenticate and gain access  to
google cloud
apis enables
server-to-server interactions in a project
users require a name and
password to authenticate however
service accounts use a
key keys are sensitive and must be
managed carefully because they provide
access to  users when you run
applications on computer and not on app
engine google manages the keys for
you and rotates them automatically however
when you run applications
elsewhere you can generate and download the
keys to use in your important code take
care to keep them safe and rotate
them frequently
a service account is an identity
but it is also a resource on the one hand
we have seen that a service account
can be used as an identity
to help the application authenticate itself for
example a compute engine virtual machine
that assumes the identity of a
service account  to communicate with
other services to grant  the
virtual machine access to the resources
with which it wants to communicate must
grant the corresponding roles and amd
to the service account
on the other hand you must control who
can create virtual machines with the
service account so that other
random virtual machines cannot
assume that responsibility
here the service account
actually behaves as a resource to be
authorized so you know start
using google for free
today in cloud dot google.com
barra free and start assigning resources
and giving permissions to users